indom non mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça tu me connais pas mon fois qu'on
ne raconte pas idiot si tu me connais
pas enfin un coup
rappelle toi le mois d'août le cap
d'agde le camp de nudistes
même si je suis désolé votre affaire ça
change tout j'ai pris mes repères
ah ben oui forcément est comme ça qu
coup la voilà
et sa troupe née
on veut dire un enjeu ans henri jean
robert le ménage au basket ou se blesser
bon j'arrive dans les courses à faire le
doberman aller chercher on finit bien
oui messieurs
ils se sont rencontrés on versait ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sétois robert sétois ginès et moi c'est
moi
rendez vous mercredi prochain place du
colonel fabien 17 heures israël
ils se sont rencontrés lors d'un stage
de plongée sous marine
est ce que c'est que ça mange à toutes
personnes qu'est-ce qui raclent petit
rappel
attention pensez à bien vous madame quoi
oui bonjour quinze jours mais parce
qu'il se passerait si catoire au
tricolore avait que les bulletins météo
non mais c'est toujours mon métier et
vous madame mais enfin tu m'appeler d'un
petit anémones de mer et fois stop les
mots petit bidon
c'est par ailleurs pour robin requins de
pierre côté palm fait au monique monique
qui rit quand on la pique
[Applaudissements]
oui mon bébé
d'abord tu mets ça tout va
1 voilà comme ça c'est pas grave voilà
on tour plonger ils se sont rencontrés
un pèlerinage à saint pierre de rome que
je suis heureuse de te revoir
on voit aussi quel bonheur leurs quinze
jours sans trois c'est long
loulou je ne voyais plus le bout rendez
vous l'an prochain au sommet du mont
blanc là au moins nous serons plus
tranquille ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]